life on the road it's a taco dangling or
strippers waving guns and these flights
canceled flights running with the London
black this bounced checks great a
bachelorette thumps in the front making
out for your set and mid lights doing
Gollum or missing merch turn drive a
rental car has another megachurch to
juice keys vagina Pfister cellphone is
gone
one big Law & Order marathon
texture in the road story's everybody
I'm your host more evil Ariano hmm
parley all things comedy network i wanna
brag are you part of the whole thing
scam jailers none of the other things
comedy network okay and i don't think
there's anything bragging about it at
all i think it's a great community to be
a part of I said I didn't want to brag
ya know it's not bragging sure sounds
good yeah sitting in with me today is
comedian Jay Larson and in the co-host
seat today here I don't want an only
Gary bright well coming back how you
doing buddy wow it has been a while
since I've seen you what's new not much
just off the road it's a strong you
speak up but Gary I think right well
figured well yeah you're gonna need to
speak up Gary
yeah just first time you and I wouldn't
met yeah yeah you're gonna need to speak
up Gary what I'm eating the mic boards
I didn't fry them you're a piece of [ __ ]
sitting this is the thing he sent a
comedian here tried to do something that
a professional does and what do you do
she just set the levels and then
spot-weld them just so they're there I
have set the levels and then my kid gets
into you starts playing with the knobs
so does mine well that's why I have that
one that that broken mixer up there is
one my kid plays why don't you just use
like white out and put white out there
so you know that's like where the level
should be yeah you know what I'm gonna
do the tape you know I'm gonna do that
cuz I said too because I had a dream
about this show
last night I forgot about it till just
now it was me a girl I went to high
school with named Kamala Malik where's
goes deeper than we thought this is so
weird
my dad God rest his soul
no he sees me but eventually that'll
apply at some point when someone hears
no I'm gonna see him next week so I'll
tell him that you wish him well after he
dies sure and he's a preacher he's fine
he's gonna have is he still preaching
he's retired you retire from that
yeah he just preaches to anyone he meets
he just stop really retired is like I'm
just gonna say with comedy I feel like
it's what it is no one's gonna care no
one's no little party and be like hey
he's done big retirement party people
give like didn't you didn't you didn't
you
Jesus kinda it's a and you so it was me
Kamala Malik you and my dad were sit
down to do this podcast mmm
Gary might even hear I don't remember
and then my dad couldn't hear Gary yeah
my dad looked at the knobs and just went
zero zero zero zero I'm like dad what
are you doing he's like we gotta set the
levels we just want you to hear the Lord
so sorry I went off on that dream rant I
apologize he didn't go to 666 oh you
know what you know what you know what my
dad now my dad works at Hertz rent-a-car
are you kidding me yeah there's no
retirement plan and uh preachers you can
get the insurance for you have been
mistaking my like what is good dude you
could do a whole web series on what your
dad could do for work after a time and
its features and the different jobs that
would be [ __ ] is so funny I tried to
do a web series of Hannibal Lecter
trying to like ingratiate himself or
like get back in the real world after
getting out of jail so I did one where
he like tried to become like who went
and interviewed to be a roommate with
people and then became their roommate
huh and then one week he like tried to
become a bartender and got a job
bartending and it was like you know in
the roommate one someone's like going
the bathroom and he pops a pilot tub
like what's the matter Jordan are you
looking for toilet paper but you can't
escape the feelings you like you don't
have raise like he's always leavin the
milk ampionship like why do you need the
milk does it say yes so anything so
you've been off the road gara yeah
no no more private jets for a while no
no I haven't no I've worked with a
involve over a year and a half now Oh
get it really yeah let me hear tell me
about the private jet experience we went
to okay here's the greatest thing about
the private jet when I first when he
first how long did you open for him mmm
what five years for five years oh
there's a good friends yeah he treats
his people well yeah I'm not I mean well
cuz you know I think a lot of people
don't know this but like you can go open
for certain guys there was some guys a
couple guys that took care of me and I
know guys headliners that really take
care of their openers
and then other headliners that are doing
really well and they just like oh yeah
you get what you get and that's it
but I heard that angle always took care
of yeah it was really it was a great gig
but the first time we took the jet it
was like you know we had to wait to get
the jet in fan eyes so I'd to drive all
the way to Van Nuys from Redondo Beach
on Wayne Airport but it's like the
planes leaving at 12:10 I go what time
do I need to be here those 1209 that's
that's the best part about it there's no
there's no standing in a TSA line and
valet your car right I sometimes day
yeah usually can just drive right out to
the car I mean right out to the plane
and then just give the keys to the guy
and he just yeah I mean come on I'm 33
what was the farthest you flew cuz I
don't care if your own private jet if
it's going to Vegas you like yeah you
want to enjoy all the way across oh you
know to Carolinas or Bordeaux or
you know the greatest thing that is is
also you do the show let's say you're in
Peoria Illinois mm-hmm you do the show
go straight to the airport get on a
plane and you fly home you're laying in
bed it still may be 3:00 in the morning
but you're like I just did a show in
Peoria my own bed so gross that told me
that when he did I think he did Vegas
with Tosh and it was the same thing Tosh
soon as they left boom out the door
because anyone who's doing private jets
have been doing it long enough to know
that you don't want to be [ __ ]
hanging around yeah right that's crazy
and you just go to the next town next
city and then somebody picks you up
takes you the hotel and then you know
that way the pilots can sleep all night
and their money for the next day we just
doing one-niners or yes yeah just do one
night in one city one night nothing and
kind of what were the how big were these
audiences 3,000 Oh biggest audience one
time I opened for sports another college
and it was like 6300 kids Wow
but that was the only time after that I
think the next was a 2000 which was like
once and then after that like you know a
couple
500 there I think I'm a 1500 1600 that's
not it I mean but 3,000 on the Reg not
only that you're going to 3,000 people
that are all there intentionally yeah
people like hey should we check out
comedy tonight yeah right there
say what will you do with Reagan's the
same thing it's just Brian he's on a
tour bus yawn one minute on a tour bus
the good thing is that you open for
Regan earning vol so much they're there
to see you two probably you probably
pick up some fans along the way I don't
think I do no no it's nice to be you
know in to be thought of an inn Brian
Regan's world and Bill Engvall I am a
good night they liked me enough to have
me on the road with them because I'm not
a pain in the ass I'm right easy to get
along with exactly I open for him the
last Club date he ever did oh yeah yeah
oh yeah and I had no idea I was like
ignorant standup I didn't be like grew
up like loving stand-up or anything or
knowing much about span it seems to end
up twice before I ever did it so my
manager called me and said hey you got
booked to host for Brian Regan Irvine
next weekend I was like oh awesome cool
he goes alright and I'm like all right
and he goes do you know Brian Regan is I
think you'd be more excited and I go no
and he goes dude you're like this is
like waits you see this guy and I
remember like him murdering her like the
straight hour just murdering and just
being in awe yeah hundred percent clean
not even damn or hell came out his mouth
right and I was just so impressed I call
it the him and Engvall do it to it
it's the turbulent see audience
especially in a club you see it in a
club where they're on a row they're just
hammering the crowd and the crowd is
just yeah it's just like weird
turbulence see heads moving it's just
it's really it's really amazing to watch
these guys yeah for sure
no I can't tell my Brian Regan stories
I've told him way too many times on the
show so I'm gonna pass okay pass it up
four years ago
I remember going up to him though and
just like after like first two nights
and be like hey can I ask you you know I
was hosting and he would just kind of
like stick to himself like just go stand
by the bar and I was like hey can I ask
you something say I'm like why why are
you cleaning like what is it and he goes
well there's just so many other words in
the dictionary that you could use
instead of those words and I was like oh
my god this guy's right I'm like I was
clean that's why I got the gig but like
I wasn't a hundred percent clean and
then after that I just went clean for
like eight years
yeah now yeah i'ma like I mean I'm still
kind of clean but like I can go clean in
a second but well he told me when he was
on the show that he should they join the
other names that are on the floor what
was that he's like because I asked him
about I guess everybody asked him about
it and he's like well he's like I don't
sit down and write I'm gonna write the
cleanest joke ever yeah you know he's
just like that's the way I have always
been when we would do stupid little
sketch sketches at home with me and my
friends it was always the goofy you know
weird stuff that he liked yeah
so you just it's not like he's it's not
intentional that's just him yeah yeah
all kinds of comedy he's like a huge
Dave Attell fan he loves all that he
just others in a word or yeah he just
prefers to work that way
Jimmy borer oh I heard he beats dogs is
that true Ryan rege yeah those his wife
his wife beats dogs
I got in trouble once though with him oh
I was gonna ask you about that I used to
open for him in the clubs too but then I
started doing the theatres with him so I
just thought it was you know same as the
club's you know so I had jokes where I
was a really super dirty but I you know
are worse than cursing but I had you
know content that was a little bit a
little bit off yeah and then you don't
realize you look down there's like an
eight-year-old sitting up front Wow
so I did this and this a particular I
mean I just did a regular show and the
week
the weekend was over and I didn't think
you know didn't think anything of it and
then like four or five weeks later I'm
on another to run with him but I get a
phone call before I'm leaving from his
manager who's on vacation in Mexico I'm
like oh this guy I'm out of his vacation
to tell you about the man yeah so it was
basically a reprimand thing saying that
some people had complained at the last
show and Brian had felt like you know
now what did you Brian and I we're good
friends he was like no I don't want to I
don't want to kick him off and not use
him anymore but he needs to know that's
what I was and I yeah it was like oh man
I don't do you remember what you said
cuz I remember it wasn't that horrible
it wasn't like yours or anything like
that no it's just stuff that if you if
you have a you know a 9 10 12 year old
kid that might not know something you
have to explain something on the way
home you know yeah you would have put
out mean yeah yeah it's like you know
daddy what do you felt you mean yeah
crazy yeah yeah so you just just now you
just steer away from anything like that
I just did the idea of performing for
children just gives me nightmares
I can't I hate it I've done it crushing
the poor kid now you do good my case
they wasn't crushing for the cast
crushing I think for us and he was just
like they're actually crushing for my
wife yeah wife was laughing he's like
nah I cuz I thought I was gonna take one
of his beds I used to have a nephew and
I would always like kids have no concept
that things are owned or bought right
thing
so I used to tell my nephew all-time
that I was gonna take some of his stuff
anybody know you can't take it I'm like
I'll buy it from you and he's like what
no it's like not for sale but now I'll
just pay for it you know I'll buy it and
he's like no I it's not for sale Bo I'm
like yeah but everything's for sale and
he would lose his mind cuz all of a
sudden his he would start like computing
like oh my god people have money and
they buy things and he's gonna buy my
[ __ ] and he would freak out even gonna
buy my kid your bed you're just gonna
take it yeah I actually made my son cry
the other night and I did not mean to we
play on the bed all the time before bed
like I'll get them up there and toss
them around the pillow
stuff and he loves dinosaurs right now
so when I go I hope what's that he looks
at me he's look not even - I go is there
a dinosaur another bed
is there a dinosaur coming to get us is
it done now he won't even go in our room
oh really on the day he walked by and
looked at my wife he goes dinosaur
pointed under the bed he thinks his
dinosaur there my kid thinks there's
sharks under ours idiots kids are so
dumb so dumb what's been going on with
you Jay your sunglasses this is how you
conduct interviews what's been going on
with you where you Byron Allen yeah here
you have you have a funny story about a
cell phone there Byron Allen I'll kick
you off the show right now you think
about those prescription they were
prescription they [ __ ] me up I didn't
realize yet such shitty eyesight check
this out prescription do you have
prescription sunglasses right you have
glasses okay so I went in and with my
eyewear my eye insurance see there you
go
I had already had glasses but I had to
go get a new prescription filled and
they said Oh with your insurance you get
eighty percent off a pair of glasses and
then you get 50% off a second pair of
glasses and I already had it see those
are nice those are nice I already had
glasses so I go you know what why don't
I just get prescription sunglasses at
80% and 50% off and I walked out of
there with two pairs of sunglasses that
a prescription play this is the story
you tell on an interview it's what I've
been up to people also what give him
peace man give him life hacks I had oral
surgery recently really yeah you ever
had my surgery no would you have wisdom
teeth yep how old were you young I think
I was in as a freshman high school okay
at this is what I just had a all of them
evolved Liz all four wisdom teeth I had
an infection in a tooth that's in front
of the Woodsen - okay and it got
infected and then the back one was
infected mine are all impacted so the
guy basically had to take out that tooth
and he's like when I take out all your
wisdom teeth and that teeth and I got a
bone graph but I mean I was in the
emergency room for like four hours and
nine ten pain and just like waiting and
really I didn't get and then they just
novocaine dit and then blew up my whole
mouth it was like a literally a
three-week process
back and get an implant all that stuff
they put you to sleep though yeah all
right I came out on fire oh yeah oh yeah
into the elevator there's like an old
woman I just I just grabbed her she's
like 86 and I go come on I need you and
my wife is like dying she goes oh he's
on drugs and I look at I go I'd be doing
this anyway I had a tooth pulled at the
free clinic when I first moved to town
it was the worst Road comics have to do
is go to free clinics go to the free
clinic and this guy this dentist was
there I must have been his community
service because he didn't want to be
there and he walks it he's like so
what's what's wrong today I'm like you
tell me you're the dentist and take a
look in there he's like I don't have
time for this what's wrong oh man I have
a really bad toothache and he looks at
he goes all right we're gonna have to
pull that tooth so you just just looked
at it and said that ya shot me one thing
I've know became got basically pliers
yeah
gripped it pulled it out didn't so it
gave me like a thing of gods and said
bike down on that change at every
half-hour and left oh my god did you
ever get it replaced no no oh dentistry
in the Congo to sit on a folding chair
and I cut the tooth and had you know
rips the grips from the from the yeah
but his foot up on the chair to get
deployed man it's no gentle it out he
put his foot up on the chair asleep yeah
that's the thing you had no insurance I
take it oh yeah no have you ever had to
do anything with no insurance mmm cuz
your communion with I had to do it STD
oh no really STD what I how did you get
that from an ex stay away once you close
that door don't open it back up okay you
can't you can't spell sex without ex
buddy oh good point yeah and nothing
like breakup sex sex with a girl that
you used to be with you know yeah
that's why me and my wife will role play
it once in a while like get the [ __ ]
back in here
and I had to go clinic and get the STD
from a kid he loves that Qbert yeah
break let's bring it in here Sebring was
it and then I had to so I had to go to a
clinic and get tested
luckily my friend was a urologist right
and I just called her I'm like hey this
is what's going on she's like alright
I'll write you two prescriptions go get
them
I've had a legal prescriptions done for
me a couple times really that time well
no one should I never had health
insurance wait what did you have though
I don't know I never got diagnosed
someone or whatever no wasn't penicillin
it was like I don't know what these two
things were I took him for like seven
days then went back to the clinic got
tested clear okay then we knew you had
an STD but you don't know what it was
yes yeah I don't need to get into like
the Cynthia we're good let's get a
notepad but then the other time I got
the flu and I got real I've never been
sick like all through growing up I was
never sick once I never missed a day of
school that I wasn't skipping and I got
sick and I had no insurance and like I
was going on like four days and I caught
I had a friend who was a nurse and she's
like all right and she she snagged a
shot of penicillin out of the ER what
and came over my house and she's like
all right I'm she's like yeah you
definitely are in bad shape
I'm gonna just give you a shot of
penicillin I go alright and she's like
you know where you know where I have to
give this to you right I'm like yeah in
the butt right and she's like yeah I'm
like all right she's like you're okay
with that I'm like well like not
directly in my [ __ ] right no I'm fine
let's do it
and it was unbelievable have you ever
done penicillin I probably have snorted
it once no you did it was the greatest
drug I've ever had really
it took that flu and beat the [ __ ] I
like and literally in like four hours I
was ready to go
wow I stay I don't go to doctors all
right it's my Warren Zevon approach to
life so you know no matter how slightest
we can decide us that hurt yeah wait did
they take it out yeah who it was I'm
surprised more people don't die from
that because all it is is a stomach ache
you have a really bad stomach ache and
you do everything in your power to
remedy a stomach ache and then finally
just go I gotta go to go to the doctor I
gotta go I gotta go to the hospital huh
but you don't want to go to hospital
because you know they're like look at
mr. tummyache but then this witch told
me there was insecure thing I've ever
heard
that's your guy that pull your tooth
would have been let me tell you the
minute they tell you oh you got
appendicitis you're like thank God I
have it right I do I do [ __ ] leave it
in [ __ ]
yeah and they gave me dilaudid yeah
that's just a single Michael Jackson ran
now he was on propofol okay but I heard
that my buddy who's Sickler was just
under loaded oh yeah yeah it's like it's
nitro someone pours hot honey overtop of
you it's just that Oh pain goes away and
you're just you're just floating really
nice I had a kidney stone get one
appendix though that's what cichlid just
had oh really yeah I had kidney stones
before I was heading out to Denver to do
shows oh and I can I get happened on
like Monday and I was like oh man and
then they went away I passed him or
whatever and I was like I I don't want
to be on a plane and have him come back
or I don't want to be in Denver in the
middle of nowhere and have him come back
that was the worst yeah
but I did I so would you pass them
before you left yeah I have knocking on
wood I think I've told the story here
before I've very I can pass them myself
without going to the I've had them like
three or two or three times what and
they're very mild and it's only like a
really shitty for like a half hour and
just just when I'm about to like call
911 oh oh I'm sorry
well Sickler was a little [ __ ] that you
were talking about yeah I look I'm a
rarity I am a rarity as a matter of fact
when I went back to the doctor he's like
oh the doctor the next day you know to
get checked out and the factor said dude
you have insurance go to the hospital
take a bunch of drugs and watch movies
next time this happens don't don't sit
at home and do it yourself yeah of
course and then you get sympathy from
your wife and you're not doing anything
yeah it's tight that's tight so what you
been up to Jay back with medical talk
after there's nothing worse than being
on the road though and being sick Oh
doing shows and you're just deathly sick
yeah no well that's the thing that
people forget you have no comforts when
you're on the road so all you do is you
look for shitty food yeah
you look for horrible TV you look for
booze yeah you know I mean nuts yeah
what'd you do a lot of times you like
not even like I said wherever the condo
is that there's no stores around so
you're trying to you know you're trying
to medicate yourself with something
anything that's at the 7-eleven yeah
exactly
what is your go to 7-eleven pick I have
mine dude what is it
it's the tuna sandwich on wheat but they
have them they're like super packed up
and they're super soft people people get
shady on them but just check the date
you're good and then do I either do I'll
get like a raspberry Snapple iced tea
and then it's either gonna be a half can
of sob cream and on your Pringles sour
cream and onion
Friday's potato skins pizzeria combos oh
yeah or French onion SunChips and then
I'll get either like a Twix or a KitKat
or a thousand grand bar that's like my
when I was you know on the road and
doing exactly that that's my go-to to
come back to I mean boom I get a little
bit everything Sports Center goes on
yeah I'm feeling your pizzeria combos
man that's an East Coast thing ro
I love combos you have combos on the
west coast you're here here yeah they
are oh yeah everywhere I don't eat that
7-eleven is the same I haven't stepped
into 7-eleven and I don't know how long
you eat pretty good yeah are you really
healthy yeah
even on the road I'm lonely filthy I've
been a vegetarian for almost 20 years
oh you're a vegetarian who might you
tell me that before I know but what
reason is it because you like animals or
you just you think it's good for you
because how this age and I'm looking
this good yo yeah you do look good all
right Prince fielder's a vegetarian
who's that of course you don't know
supports Cecil fielder's sunny ways like
two cents huge how is he you play also
yeah Jack's homers and you battle you
have the baseball's like fishing man you
don't have to be in shape are you out of
your mind I've seen a lot of fat
baseball players can you name the only
baseball player that's also and who's in
the Hall of Fame who's also in the
fly-fishing Hall of Fame probably can't
hold on you don't even know sports how
are you but my brother's a fly fisherman
guide epidemic so
he'll he might have mentioned this do
you want yeah I'm a passing yeah
I'm trying to think what Raleigh fingers
know do you know I don't but I want to
say he's also I say catfish hunter
not just because fish I think he looks
like a guy that would be my fishing know
Ted Williams no big deal you don't even
know who Ted Williams is black Boston no
no no great assume his head's in a
cryogenic capitate his head young frozen
somewhere in Arizona you're talking
about Walt Disney no you see the same -
that's what they say but can I can we
talk about earth 2.0 do you even know
about this
no boy a hold on there's a frozen head
yeah there's a number of them dude it's
no big deal
yeah but you have the ability either for
you freeze your head or freeze your
whole body it's cheaper to freeze their
heads so they think that by the time
that science comes around you'll be able
to reattach your head and then we have
like a brand new body with a super old
head Danny can run you look like that
that guy in those airplane magazines us
real buff but he's really old flight
magazine guy yeah it's like your
grandfather from the neck up right it's
all because he he he inversion you ever
seen that guy like have you seen the
girl I would say they're very great what
we have upside but he invented this one
where you get in and you lean back and
he hangs upside down he says I feel
great like this and at the very end to
show that he feels great he decides to
jump and he literally has an inch and a
half vertical leap but look and look
what I can do and like I just stay on
the ground but these are the things you
investigate when you're in the road oh
man you guys ever done to a sensory
deprivation tank no no another thing why
you did that yeah you can do it in there
but like I did in Venice huh because Joe
Rogan's a huge fan of it right right and
he Rory Scovel heard about it right as
he was on the road and he I don't know
he came back I was like hey we should go
to this I heard about this and so we
went to it and you get in the tank
there's no light it's pitch black
there's no sound
and you get into warm salt water so you
float you know what I mean we can float
and you dip your ears back in it and you
just stay in there and you meditate and
you're like you don't know you've no
sense of time you have no sense of
anything right is it just salt water is
there anything else
high-density salt well hi-de-ho Missa
you know it's not like there's Morton's
in there I was in there 45 minutes you
just see colors and you enjoy it you try
to meditate now for me it was a little
like I mean I feel like maybe it's
something you get into but it was just
like forcing it a little bit for me I
was just like hey what's going on here
blah it was i but I didn't do it again
mm-hmm they didn't see colors or
anything maybe I saw colors I don't know
why you change your life have you are
you watching making a murderer I am a
time and Episode four so don't ruin it
okay episode 1 okay I'm on Episode eight
but you're like the cops being like you
sure you didn't see colors that's
awesome
tell me you saw colors because like
colors colors color I didn't see it
purple tell me you saw purple these guys
yeah it's so it's so terrible it's so in
like and my wife was like this is I
don't like this I don't like the way
it's they're playing it out it's like a
reality and then like episode 4 she's
like oh my god dude no lie what my wife
the same thing she goes from we're
watching it and she'll just be sitting
there and this is I don't know if it's
because we're comedians and we pay
attention to everything but like she'll
sit there and text or like answer an
email like while the shows on and then
then be done with it and look and she's
like oh my God look at this and I'm like
what are you you just rotate now you're
you need to shout in disapproval we'll
just shut up I'm fine with it just just
watch yeah so I'm excited to see the
rest of it oh wait till lunch
don't da here's another thing on the
road do you see movies I always tell
myself I'm going to and I don't cuz you
have to go to matinees right yeah yeah
you can't move again yeah i binge watch
Netflix when I go Halle Road it just
means you're in the hotel yeah you know
I did last last time I was on the road
second last time I was on the road had a
weekend
Thursday Friday Saturday and I had been
pitching a TV idea
and I sold it and they were like but
waiting like they were just like waiting
for questions and my my agent says to me
he's like well did you write the script
on this and I'm like no why should I
is it now that's okay and I'm like wait
are you telling me I should have a
script written you think no I'm just
saying to be better if you did it's not
a big deal I'm like alright next day got
up order room service it was one of
those gigs it was a room service it was
have you done in Coronado Island Laugh
Factory oh no no yes dude it's like a
resort yeah yeah room service
yeah they give you that you get paid
then they give you a per diem that you
can spend every day what it is a
Starbucks there so I literally got room
service for breakfast sat at the desk
and row for four hours straight and
wrote the pilot then went hopped in the
pool came back showered and then went
out to dinner on the property before I
went to my show I felt [ __ ] amazing
gee man that's that's the kind of gig
that people think we do every night of
the week you know those are the gigs
that keep you in the game
right you know if you constantly got you
know the [ __ ] gigs bang but where you're
just getting the you know getting it
knocked out of yet you would never
continue you like where's the yeah
what's the payoff yeah where's the fun
no I know well that's the one let me
tell you what the payoff was here's the
deal though unbelievable set up the
shows suck no really sucked I mean it
was like you're at a resort and you know
you're not like George Lopez that's
who's drawing man you're probably it's
probably bunch of rich people yeah it
was crazy town yeah it was crazy it was
just was not I would think like some of
the locals that live on that island
would like come see the show no it's
like and you've looked at every week it
was like George Lopez Kevin Nealon like
huge names I was a filling they called
me like three weeks before like hey can
you do this and I'm like yeah and you
know the best thing was just getting
away from like the kids like I'd be like
oh I could sleep in and not worry about
it but then I then I wrote that thing
and those end up being the best but I
saw hateful eight right this was gonna
be my whole movie thing and I have a gag
I like to do to people well I got
pretend them on the phone and I'll start
talking about the person that's right
next to me but I do it loudly right
something like that so I'm with this guy
and we go into the bathroom before we're
gonna go see the movie you know and Kurt
Russell's in the movie so we go in and
there's like tons of dudes is using
urinals so I just pull out my phone I'm
like hey man now we just left not suck
dude Kurt Russell died in the first 15
minutes all right I'll call you later
and then I left hoping that he hear it
and be like oh my god that's [ __ ]
hilarious and everyone else go what the
[ __ ] trying to pee so we get outside I'm
talking one of the other guys I'm with
and this dude comes out like pissed
steaming and he just walks up to us and
we're like what's going on is like
[ __ ] guy just ruin the movie in there
some guy just I'm not gonna tell you
guys on a roof like total spoil alert
right before the [ __ ] movie dude I'm
pissing guy drops this thing and I go
dude that was me bro and he goes what I
go yeah Kurt Russell 15 minutes he goes
oh dude I was so bad I was like the kind
of [ __ ] you got to do to entertain
you're so that's hilarious
that's a man that's that's ballsy that
dude turn around somebody who any of
those people somebody f you up man but
that's what you do just what like when
there's a huge movie and everyone's
waiting in line you just walk down past
the line on the phone like you don't
even see them now dude
whole movie sucked you know and then
drop a spoiled I was not true I was I
did a gig was it last night two nights
ago and it and it was late but it wasn't
late like so late that I couldn't stop
by the bar and have a drink and then go
to bed you know what I mean so I stopped
by the bar and it's a bar around the
corner from my house and I had a drink I
know the bartender said wait a minute
over here yeah that dive over there I've
always wanted to go place smells always
it seems like dancing and stuff no they
think no it's called a dining no dancing
and cocktails Ryze is there like there's
no dancing at all and cocktails is a
strong word and it always smells like
deviled eggs do they have no legs no
it's disgusting they're so smells like
your car there were three guys talking
about making of a murder or whatever
it's called and it got into the guys
like I did and I went whoa some of us
haven't seen I was some of us around on
Episode four and the dude you would have
thought I just insulted his daughter
like he eats jerk
stopped and looked at me and just glared
at me I said I can move to the other
side of the bar
that guy was pissed
he was principal he's telling the whole
thing loudly yeah he's pulling the Jay
Larson to actually somebody though but
he was doing for reals yeah yeah for
reals [ __ ] that guy you got a story you
wanted to tell us um I have a couple
nice kidnapping my child out there I
think it might be your wife okay I don't
think anyone could kidnap your child you
have to be Lawrence Taylor up in Jersey
I'm not that much cocaine right LT was a
chance right yeah he was giants yeah my
goat might go to football reference is
Terrell Owens what do you mean if I ever
need a punchline for with a with an
athlete it Strela ones just say Terrell
oh and then you think that it's a tee oh
yeah I'll just say Terrell Owens all
right
I do it I used to do a joke about my
wife wearing a no strip to bed and it
was like going to bed with Terrell Owens
there you go BAM okay but did he retire
like 20 years ago or something not 20
but he's retired he isn't I have to
update that reference if I ever do that
joke again it's yeah you should
it's stupid to because that guy's the
second like third best to I receive it
ever play the game and everyone just
looks at him like a joke because he has
such a little [ __ ] and complain oh no
really yeah cuz with the cocaine no he
didn't do cocaine that was Lawrence
Taylor he was like a physical specimen
tio he'd held a press conference in his
front yard doing sit-ups with no shirt
on you know what he couldn't do breathe
through his nose cuz he wore no stress
you know he was getting the most out of
everything he had he was an overachiever
man you know that oxygen yeah okay to
make it the machine to run so that's the
only role and everyone's well I'll use
the phrase cause call inaudible call
inaudible yeah other than that zilch and
why we so Gary and I used to co-host
Bill engvall's radio show oh yeah
and when bill wasn't there Gary get
pissed because he couldn't talk about
baseball I couldn't lose your team
angels angels really you know angels
who's your team the Red Sox yeah they
play at Foxboro now they can wait
to the greatest ballpark in the history
school no please wait a minute you just
upset because cuz Dave Henderson hit a
home run off Donnie Moore no I'm not ex
I'm not upset at all I would tell you
right now Moore was he killed himself oh
hey the guy more killed himself after
David I was lucky enough invol had
season tickets box seats and I get to go
to a lot of games and I got to see a lot
of the fans from the other teams and the
Red Sox fans were the biggest dicks why
they just they were they weren't it they
were worse than theirs New York thought
they were worse than Yankee fans here's
the thing Yankee fans like yeah we beat
you Red Sox fans are like we [ __ ]
beat you they're like in your face about
it it was I was like yeah I'm not like
that no I mean yeah of course
idiot you know it's funny is I used to
[ __ ] on Yankee fans to people look cuz I
I went to Yankee Stadium one time and
and I was there with my friend Robin who
didn't know anything about baseball
and David Ortiz was up and I got off
David Ortiz I was just like filling her
in on everything I'm like the best this
guy's the best clutch hitter in all of
baseball this guy turns and goes you
think is better than Alex Rodriguez and
I go as far as clutch ballplayers go
yeah damn I think he much definitely is
he goes you're out of your mind and I'm
like you're delusional and then BOOM
David Ortiz hits a home run and I go
pretty clutch bro and I was like and I
had this like talk with someone like
about Red Sox fans versus Yankee fans
and I'm like dude Yankee fans are
freaking animals yeah you know what I
mean and this guy goes my friend went to
a Red Sox game with a Yankee hat on and
someone ripped it off or and lit it on
fire and I was like that's discussion
over angel fans were the biggest pansies
I mean we people give up their box seats
when they're playing the the Red Sox
because they can sell or they can sell
them for yeah that's smart no it's a
Disney we had a monkey that was that
their rally monkey
that wasn't rally monkey house I was a
doctor there centerfielder was a punter
in college Darren Ernst ed he was also
like all he was like all-american punter
at Nebraska I guess here soon if you
don't now is Mike Trout out my proudest
I would have the best I saw you to it
that he is your real deal baby is man I
saw you two in angel angel Stadium right
out in center field that's cool born me
to sleep over here with this [ __ ]
baseball top so one time I was doing a
road gig in New York New York New York
State or City know the city okay um but
it was like one of those gigs I'm like
I'll just stay at my buddy's house and
I'll just see if I can get per diem for
the hotel you know I mean you ever done
that no it's like you know like a club
gets you up in the hotel and you're like
oh I don't need the hotel you let's see
if we can get money on that side okay
instead of getting the hotel so I just
staying with my buddy so I roll in I go
see him he lives in like the Lower East
Side and I go meet him in the afternoon
and the gig was like two nights away but
I was doing it like I was like I'll do
other shows for that gig it was like I
was doing like some corporate gig right
which are the best people hate them I've
had bad corporates and good corporates
this is a good I was like literally
hosting an event and got paid crazy
money for it I'm like guys anytime you
want me to come back so wear suit yeah
head of where it talks
oh what's talk so you have to rent it
yeah heard they ran it for you no I
rented it alright but it was like 120
bucks I came up from DC rented it rented
in DC took the train up stayed at my
buddy's did a show in Brooklyn that
night stay to his house did the gig the
next night went out to dinner with him
went back to DC so I'm there and that
that night the night before I'm doing a
show in Brooklyn and so I go to see him
beforehand he gives me a key to the
front of the building key to his key to
his place I go to Brooklyn to go do the
show then I'm coming back to see him
we're gonna go out to dinner right so I
get back it's about 11:15 go in the
building go up one flight of stairs down
the hall up a flight of stairs down the
hall there he is apartment 8 get to the
door and the key to the door doesn't
work so he gave me the right key
downstairs it was just the wrong key
upstairs so I knock on the door cuz it's
the wrong key you know and like all my
friends I don't know about you guys but
any friend I have who's not a comedian
right thinks there are committee
and he comes to the door he's like who
is it you know and I'm like looking
through the peephole and I'm like it's
me dude
open the door the keys keys not working
he goes nobody home and I go all right
dude I opened the door man come on and
like this couple comes by like with
groceries and I'm like how you doing
like I trust me I know I'm and I'm like
come on dude this is ridiculous the keys
not working like I'm holding him he's
like go away no one's here so I kicked
the door a couple times like let's go
dude come on I'm not you know like was
late at night right it's 11:15 right so
then I sit there and I just like alright
let me just let him enjoy his moment he
and his girl will probably like laughing
about it so I just sit back and I wait
like 30 seconds and I'm like I'll wait
30 seconds and then I'll knock and be
like come on like you got it 30 seconds
I wait and then I hear him making a
phone like a fake phone call you know
kind of like I liked it like to do yeah
he's going there is man at my door he
has key he's kicking door in I'm like
come on dude like this is stupid
you know like I'm not buying that you're
calling the cops right now and he's like
you must come now he's kicking he has
key now I have certain Jason Bourne like
instincts the comedian and when I
remember coming up there that day with
my bags I gonna came up the I went
upstairs down the hallway up the stairs
the banister there I remember like
putting my hand on it and taking the
corner and it was like a loose banister
top right and so I'm sitting there I'm
like why I'm in the wrong building like
what if this what's the chances I'm just
in the wrong building
I'm like go check that banister top and
if it's not loose you're in the wrong
building so he's doing his police call
thing I just walked down check the
banister not loose oh and I'm like oh
[ __ ] and it's like I'm not afraid I
don't know why I'd be afraid of him
right but it's just like I'm in the
wrong plate you know I'm not suppose to
be there it was just scary so I sprinted
down the stairs down the hallway and as
I'm about to go down the second set of
stairs I hear his door like opening and
I'm like oh my god oh my god
like you know like you're like in the
dark and your friends start running
right so I get outside and I look at the
building and right next to this door
front is another door front they're both
painted red it's the same thing I'm like
oh my god go with the key work
worked in both doors that's the weirdest
place that the kid worked in both dogs
get to it I know
oh he's weird okay so I go sprint up the
stairs down the hallway sprint up the
stairs down the hallway key in the door
works opens it up I'm out of breath my
buddy's there and I come barreling in
like Kramer and he's like what's going
on you're not gonna believe what just
happened and he's like what is going on
I'm like dude I just went to the wrong
apartment
and he goes what apartment you go to
it's 8:00 I'm like I went to 8:00 and he
goes what are you talking about I'm like
in the building next door and he's like
what I'm like yeah dude and there's some
old guy in there I know if he's Russian
or Yugoslavian but there's some old dude
and he called the cops on me cuz I was
kicking his door and he goes why were
you kicking his door I go and he goes no
way and I go dude I'm telling you I was
kicking the door I was like yelling to
him like - cut the [ __ ]
I had a key I'm waiving the key in the
keyhole and he's like no way dude we go
into his bedroom and we look out the
window heat this girl's in there too -
cruises up front with the lights
spinning really so he called the cops
yeah yeah and they showed up and we're
just now they're losing it we're dying
they're laying on the bed we're rolling
around and I go how did the key work and
he's like I'm not was like you know what
the super for our building is the super
for that building he might just have all
the same keys to make it easier you know
I mean like it might just be the same
lock on both buildings right so I'm like
I don't know man whatever he's like well
let's just wait for the cops leave and
then we'll go eat and I was like all
right so the cops leave we walk down the
street go this place called little
Frankie's shoutout to little Frankie's
one of my favorite restaurants some of
our sponsors yep thank you so much
little Frankie's check them out at sauce
little Frankie's Frank and supper he's
got four spots and he does this
spaghetti Limone that I love so I get
the spaghetti Lamoni and then wait
what's Lamoni I'm Italian I should know
this
spaghetti limo all he does is he puts
you cooked the spaghetti and then in the
pan
he puts butter and then squeezes one
lemon like a half a lemon Ola moaning oh
yeah and then the half a lemon he leaves
in there and then he like whips it like
super fast so it emulsifies into like a
creamy sauce and then just covers the
[ __ ] out of Parmesan it's super simple
super
a little pasta water in there too okay
great I love the hey wait a minute I'm
Italian but you don't know what Lamoni
one who's not a Gianni Lamoni so you
have a spaghetti Lamoni we're drinking
whiskey talking about how hilarious that
I went in there just catching up I get
the panna cotta it is a nice vanilla
panna cotta which I love
wait a second great I'm Italian what's
being a client I call it the it's like
flan so it's like 12:45 now maybe two
yeah 12:45 almost 1:00 and the bartender
who we know is like hey guys the kitchen
of closing you wanna think I'm like yeah
let me get another spaghetti Lamoni so I
get another spaghetti Lamoni
cuz I'm you know I'm trying to eat well
as healthy as well when I'm vegetarian
and we have a vegetarian get back to his
place at 130 130 in the morning okay
it's summertime so we're out front he's
smoking a cigarette we're calling our
buddy down in Atlanta to catch up you
know we're drunk so his back is to the
building I'm facing him while he's on
the call smoking a cigarette and he's
like swaying back and forth and we're
talking like to our buddy he's in the
phone but I'm telling things to say he's
telling me things back and all of a
sudden it's like he's swaying like when
he would come to his left over his right
shoulder I just saw this like little
dude in like a white t-shirt and like
big bottle cap glasses and like slicked
back like salt-and-pepper hair but he
was short and stocky you know what I
mean and I was like guys just staring at
me like ready to fight and like must
have been in the 60s maybe 70s just
staring at me I'm like [ __ ] this guy's
deal and I'm a little drunk you know so
I'm like just looking at him then Jason
would pop into frame and Obadiah and
then I'd see him again like what is this
guy's deal and then like I'm hearing the
voice of that guy behind the door and
just fits this guy's rips oh it's that
guy behind it I don't know okay it looks
whoo I heard behind the door and I'm
just like like oh look at Jason I'm like
I think that's the guy he's like what
I'm like I think that's like I'm wearing
the same thing I had on before you know
what I mean if I am the guy and he is
the guy he's looking at me like oh this
is the dude and I mean it's late dude
it's like 1:30 1:45
so Jason yourself a phone and I and
guys literally 15 feet away from me and
I go should I go say something he goes
yeah you got it so I walk right up to
him and I go hey man you live in
apartment 8 which is a little creepy and
if I was the guy and now I'm asking him
again and he doesn't say anything he
just looks at me and I go do you mad do
you know me
I was I at your door earlier I had the
key trying to get in your place
even creepier fits him he doesn't say
anything now I have to hear him say
something if I'm gonna know that @n you
know what I mean
because he has such a distinct voice
yeah yeah doesn't say anything just
stares at me I look at Jason like do you
believe this like now I'm talking like
the guy's not even there and I go bro
apartment 8 remember me I was at your
door like 2 hours ago
now I'm just assuming it's him you don't
mean like I'm just telling him he's the
guy the guy says nothing I turn Jason
like what the hell's going on and as I
turn to Jason he just this guy just
bolts across the street goes down to
first Avenue and then cross the street
and goes in like a pizza place and I
look at Jason I'm like dude what is
going on he's like I don't know I'm like
should we wait you think yeah we gotta
wait we gotta wait for him to come back
so like 50 we just hang out there he's
having cigarettes 15 minutes later my
buddy Jason goes dude dude and the guy
is across the street like in the shadows
like just hiding like up against the
fence behind a tree and we're like what
is going on and within 30 seconds of us
seeing him a cruiser pulls up and two
cops get in a car coming right at me
Oh grabbing their batons like they're
you know billy clubs or whatever and I
and I just start laughing and I go
pretty sure I know why you're here guys
and they come out I'm like did this now
this guy comes over he's standing with
them I'm like did he call you I tried to
get a news apartment I had a key did he
tell you all that and the guys are like
yeah what's going on I'm like here's the
deal man and my buddy Jason is like on
it and he's got his idea with this
address and I'm like I went into the
wrong building they're both apartment 8
I went into his building thing in his
blah blah blah and I think these cops
must have been on the first call because
they got like huge smiles on their face
and they're like thinking because that
guy was probably losing his [ __ ] little
do they know it's just this drunk dude
it was in the wrong building you know
and this guy was probably like thinking
people coming to murder him right yeah
not only was I trying to knock his door
down with my kicking in I had a key like
I had a key to his home that's what he
thinks like who the [ __ ] has a key to my
home and why is he telling me so the
guys turn to the guy and they explain it
he still hasn't said anything and I goes
all right and like I'm looking at the
guy I'm like oh we you know what I mean
is everything good and the cops are like
yeah you're good I'm like so I'm good to
go and like yeah and I look at the guy
I'm like are you all right I'll be good
doesn't say anything and I'm like all
right so Jason and I just like walk back
like weird like kind of bummed we'd like
it was like such a letdown
and then the guy goes let me ask you one
question Princess Bride and we're like
yeah dude like we turn around like
anything you want you can ask and he
goes did my landlord send you and I I
was so like blown back and had a little
drunk I wish I had said something
different but I was like no man like
first of all no one's getting sent
anymore you know I mean right what are
we in Youngstown no one's being sent
what are you why would someone be sent
for you and what kind of shady [ __ ] do
you have going on yeah that he would and
I said no but I wish I had been like you
[ __ ] know we did and watch your
[ __ ] back because he still thought
something was going on what do you think
he's running from I don't know man we're
hiding I don't know if he's like
trafficking right you know what I mean
or you know who knows but I can just
like picture him in there like you know
living like a like a Tennessee Williams
play in there you know just one table
with a light like for dick smashing
chairs and just sitting there like a
tile floor with like a yellow fridge and
it's super hot in there why was your
first assumption trafficking I don't
know I think that happens a lot with the
Eastern Bloc yeah yeah it's a pretty
dark place you ever seen taken Liam
Neeson yeah Liam Neeson's Leeson's she
taken two taken three yeah you ever seen
that Keane pill sketch no with Liam
Neeson so it's like when they both play
valets and they they get like super
excited like they just be in valets and
they're like you see that you see that
movie take and then like what show
oh but taken though but Liam Neeson
man Liam Neeson's though but like taken
and like they just get [ __ ] crazy
excited what everything here's something
that you would be surprised to find out
about Murray I love their football
sketch with the names oh my god it's
hilarious yeah they're great
I don't like football you know well you
don't like sports I don't know
no big sports guy your kids can get I
know totally my kid's gonna merge that
guy at the Super Bowl party when the
commercials come my friends making money
sitting in a crappy hotel god [ __ ]
Jamie caylor's on some sort of dodge
commercial or Mike Segal or you know and
so you know on staff there on TV shows
people are hosting three people that are
comedians that we know we're a [ __ ]
presenting at the People's Choice Awards
last night who Chris D'Elia really
presenting Adam Devine presenting Adam
Devine used to be the door guy to
Hollywood back when you were headlining
I mean I don't know who else was there
but those two I'm sure Kumail Nanjiani
was there oh yeah Jay Miller was right
TJ definitely I mean who else is better
than us I don't want long it's a long
list we don't have just followings I'm
gonna have to get off Instagram because
I see all people [ __ ] I'm just like
Jesus Christ yeah
anyway that story's anticlimactic though
huh no I like I like it I think would've
been great if he'd he's staring at you
you can't tell if it's you and he just
pulls out a peephole oh is this the guy
can't really tell him yeah we got time
for one more one more
like you said yeah - we don't have - no
I do I think I've told it before but it
doesn't matter we don't care right um
we're also I should tell my listeners
we're also recording for something else
also so we're kind of doing a two-in-one
thing here so if I'm not chiming in a
lot one you're welcome - ha ha ha - the
listener you're welcome and three you're
done uh Alaska have you done a lot
speaking of Alaska we have yeah where I
did
done it twice I did I've done a USO
stuff up there okay in military bases
but then I did one run with Danny via
pondo and we did look who's name
dropping now seriously we did gnome
bero-bero yeah catch you can and
Anchorage I think with a good gigs no
were they like bar bar show our gigs
yeah the one in Nome was a bar gig and
Danny and I were just we're he'll
headline one night and then I'll
headline the night yeah so he went on
that night first and said his set and he
goes alright let's bring on the next guy
here's the thing he's a very funny guy
you've seen him on this and this but
here's what you really didn't know he
loves Jagermeister
I don't have I can't do not I don't have
two jokes out of my head five shots of
Jagermeister
that's all they want to do is get you
trash yeah for sure
oh yeah all they wanted to do is give me
salmon I swear to God and we'll give you
fish and like non alike I'll bring you
some fish tomorrow night brought me fish
take home I go up there with Freddie
Lockhart and we were doing this gig and
like I first thing we do we get in we
land and it wasn't the pay wasn't great
but we heard it was gonna be great we
just heard they're gonna like they're
gonna treat you like family
so as soon as we get there like because
I've had reindeer sausage we're like no
like we're taking out right now take you
out right now to breakfast they take us
out to breakfast we get back we did a
show that night and normally there's
like a condo above this bar that you
stay in but it was like the heat was out
this isn't chill chill Koontz is it I
don't know chill couch Charlie's might
be oh guys two nights yeah yeah yeah
could be isn't that in Kodiak I don't
know I think okay but so then like they
usually stay above the bar but there was
no heat there so they put us in a hotel
so we did the first night go back to the
hotel next day they take us up in a
Cessna oh okay where it's an airplane
yes it is yeah where we do zero-gravity
dives you ever done those no I have done
those I didn't know we were doing them
Freddie's up in the front on the headset
they both had headsets not me I'm just
back there like videotaping out the
window and all sudden the plane go
up and then shoots down and you can
throw like a pencil in the air and it
floats there's like no gravity and I'm
like what the [ __ ] guys do you pass out
at all no I passed out
oh really yeah I love that you start
doing it not telling me I couldn't pass
could've passed out the other thing the
guy did which was crazy we were going
through the mountains it felt like we
were in Star Wars cuz you're like going
in and out of mountains there was like a
landing strip and he went down to the
landing strip but never landed just so
we could see how fast we were going
and just like by like houses and [ __ ]
and then they took us to a minor-league
hockey game and then we did a show that
night but we had time before the show so
we're like why don't we go to that condo
and we'll just hang out watch TV and
then we'll do the show and then we can
hang out the condo afterwards and see if
we hoping we meet some chicks or
whatever so we do the show we come
upstairs and this couple and her
girlfriend come up with us and they're
like oh you guys want to smoke some weed
well I can't we'll smoke some weed but
yeah so they bring the weed up we're all
hanging out smoking weed no big deal and
the girl the couple the girl says to the
the husband like all we need to be
getting home you know our daughters at
home I'm like oh yeah okay and as we're
talking about their kid we just hear
like the other woman just like like
banging on the table a little bit with
like a lighter and we look down and like
she looks like she's mashing up a piece
of candy oh I know what she's doing
yeah so like she's mashing up a piece of
candy and I'm baked and I'm like let's
this chick just bang this piece of candy
you know and I'm like kind of naive and
Freddie Locker goes is that coke and I
turn to him like oh [ __ ] coke right here
and she's like no no it's oxycontin oh
and I was just like Oh what like I'm
thinking like oxy that's like hardcore
and she's like yeah she's like I was
gonna knock this out before I Drive
these guys home and she just blew two
lines of oxy and then drove drove these
people home I like I like how you're
like coke was fine but oxy was hardcore
that's that's that's that's hardcore
coke doesn't come in a pill and then you
snort it coke comes as coke that's your
coke head you're doing oxy that's like a
different level that's like something
prescribed by doctors and you're getting
it and then you're manipulating into a
new way of doing it yeah plus you can
just swallow it - yeah okay she wanted
it right to go to the head all right
take it to the head that was all
that's just an interesting way to see
Alaska don't you think I just know like
like say you go on these run these these
gigs and then you just meet random
strangers and you just alright let's go
to your house you don't know you don't
know anything about him I was in I was
in Florida with Blake Clark doing
another name drop we were doing and so
we did our shows and then we went
drinking afterwards and we meet some
people at the bar they hadn't seen the
show but we're talking to him they go
ahead we're gonna go back to our our
place once you guys come with us you
guys are cool like all right cool we
getting the rent-a-car mm-hmm and we're
driving and then the guy was like yeah
you got to make a left down here and you
make another left next thing you know
we're like on this dirt road in the
glades in Florida and I'm like looking
around going I don't really and we get
out of the car and there's like a it's
like a house on stilts way in the corner
with like one little flickering light
like oh yeah we're just gonna go inside
here like this we start to walk and I
just went a week a week to Blake I go we
are we doing this right are we going in
with these people and he goes you don't
think it's a good idea I go no and he
goes alright let's go and we just
something in my head was that like I
don't this doesn't feel [ __ ] right
now say anything when you turn we're
gonna go yeah there's no but it was like
like was like a bad idea yeah you should
have this you should know plus you're in
Gator country I want to point that out
examine Gator country guys wanna thank
you for coming by today you're welcome
thing I appreciate it
Jay lives record see his house from my
window that's not true almost almost if
there wasn't a hill there I could see it
true and I never see I don't see you
know I know but it's kind of nice don't
you think
apparently I like our friendship a
little more than I do so no this is plus
when you come over you usually get a
kick down for the baby oh my god this
guy dials me in cuz his kid grows
quicker than any of the human being on
earth yeah car seat stroller is what do
you need
that today you leave my kids bed alone
no we got some stuff in the garage
everyone take a look at it uh J where
can we find you Jay Larson calm be calm
Jay Larson comedy on all social media
awesome in the crab feast podcast every
Tuesday check out the Trinity separate I
love it I had a great time on it you got
your listeners are amazing I probably
have a bunch of listeners from doing
that so what's yeah they're great fans
what's up fee stirs thanks for listening
over here Gary we're gonna find you I
met Gary Brett well comedy calm and Gary
underscore Brightwell twitter and gary
underscore bright well that's the other
one who's got the most um pin england
some home no he's got like four tweets
is bmw x5 is all about and so it is yeah
do you can have it for $500 but
everybody hit that gap in Twitter and
tell them to shake that that address
yeah I don't need underscore in my life
at Murray V on Twitter uh donation
buttons up at Road stories TV the albums
up there if you donate like I always say
if you're gonna donate money just buy
the album don't anything back I'll
believe to donate and if you donate
something big let me know you'd like an
album also so let's say you want to
donate fifty bucks my almonds only like
twelve or fifteen donate to fifty bucks
say hey I'd love an album send it right
Marie needs to buy something for his kid
to later give to DJ it's angry horse
representing guns and these fights can't
apply to running it the run black this
bounced checks great Bachelorette once
in the front making out through your
side
it's doing Gollum or missing murchman
tried the rental car has another
megachurch drink juice keys vagina
Pfister cellphone is gone
one big Law & Order marathon